Trascrizione: Katia Pagani
Revisore: Mauro Rezoagli
Rompiamo subito il ghiaccio
e diciamoci una verità:
Tutti noi, ogni giorno dobbiamo
smontare qualche pregiudizio.
E allora facciamo un test di sincerità.
Alzino la mano per favore tutti quelli
che ieri sera,
volendo scoprire qualcosa di più
sugli speaker di oggi,
non appena hanno iniziato a leggere
il mio profilo ha detto:
"Perchè mai domani dovrei andare
ad ascoltare un notaio?"
Un sacco di bugiardi!
Ok, andiamo avanti.
E allora vi presento la mia famiglia
mia moglie Flo, che è qui in prima fila,
e le mie bambine Carla e Viola.
Carla ha 11 anni e Viola ne ha 8.
Perché vi presento la mia famiglia?
Perché quello che vi sto per raccontare
non è un progetto solo mio.
È un progetto di un'intera famiglia
ed è un progetto di un'intera vita.
Io non sono un filosofo, non sono
un urbanista, non faccio politica.
Sono un cittadino normale,
esattamente come tutti voi.
Non ho i super poteri, non sono
milionario
e quello che sto facendo, insieme
a mia moglie Flo e
a una comunità di fondatori,
sognatori come noi,
è cercare di fare del nostro meglio
per migliorare il luogo nel quale
abbiamo deciso di vivere.
Ma facciamo un passo indietro.
Siamo a Boulevard de l'Hôpital,
siamo a due passi dal Jardin des Plantes
e dall'Istituto del Mondo Arabo.
Siamo a Parigi, nel 2006.
Ed è lì che decidiamo, il 5 gennaio 2006
di affittare una piccola casa a Parigi.
Mia figlia Carla è appena nata
da 20 giorni e abbiamo il desiderio,
con Flo, di vivere questo momento
così importante per la nostra famiglia
tutti e tre insieme.
Parigi è bellissima e il tempo, ovviamente
scorre veloce.
Carla sta per compiere tre anni
e dobbiamo decidere
dove vivere il nostro progetto di vita.
A me sinceramente sembrava che Parigi
fosse appena, appena più sexy di Favara,
ma mia moglie non ne voleva sentire
di vivere rincorrendoci, no?
io non avrei potuto fare il notaio
a Parigi.
E quindi avremmo dovuto fare
avanti e indietro.
Insomma, sapete come funziona
in questi casi quando marito e moglie
non sono d'accordo.
Decidemmo di ritornare a Favara.
Decidemmo di ritornare a Favara ma
facendoci una promessa:
che non ci saremmo lamentati per
quello che non c'era,
o per quello che non ci piaceva.
Non avremmo aspettato che
il capo del governo,
il Presidente della Regione o il Sindaco
di Favara ci cambiasse la vita,
avremmo fatto tutto quello che era
nelle nostre possiblità
per migliorare il nostro quotidiano,
per dare a Carla e Viola, e a tutti i
bambini di Favara un luogo migliore
in cui crescere, e soprattutto per
trovare il nostro posto all'interno
della comunità nella quale
avevamo deciso di vivere.
Io oggi, vi racconto questa storia,
che si ambienta in questo luogo
che si chiama I Sette Cortili.
Invece di comprare una villa al mare
o di comprare due stanze a Parigi
dove andare una volta l'anno
abbiamo deciso di comprare
questi piccoli ruderi
nel centro storico di Favara.
Questo luogo si chiama Sette Cortili.
È una piccola kasbah siciliana.
E qui convivono le zie, i nativi dei
Sette Cortili, noi di Farm Cultural Park
e altri amici che poco alla volta si sono
avvicinati a questo luogo.
E oggi vi porto i saluti della zia Maria.
La zia Maria ha più di 80 anni
e qualcuno ha detto che questi
Sette Cortili sono un piccolo regno, no?
E allora abbiamo deciso che la zia Maria
è la regina dei Sette Cortili.
Io sono diventato il Capo del Governo
dei Sette Cortili
e Vito, questo ragazzo super muscoloso,
con qualche problema di giustizia
alle spalle,
è il capo delle forze armate.
Ma cos'è Farm Cultural Park?
Farm Cultural Park è un centro
culturale indipendente.
Qui l'arte e la cultura diventano
uno strumento per cambiare
l'identità di una città
e per dare una dimensione di futuro.
È un luogo semplice, accogliente,
è un luogo dove è piacevole stare
ed è piacevole ritornare
perché è un luogo che cambia sempre.
È un posto dove incontri sempre qualcuno
di speciale.
Qualche volta anche qualcuno
un po' troppo speciale.
Ma è "Farm". Cos'è Farm?
Farm è anche il luogo della conoscenza
dell'educazione.
Il nostro progetto più importante sono
i bambini,
Sou, la scuola di architettura
per bambini
Pensate che durante l'anno scorso
i nostri bambini hanno incontrato
più di cinquanta docenti, architetti,
designer, filosofi,
provenienti da tutte le parti d'Italia.
Hanno incontrato pure due curatori
della Biennale di Venezia.
Con loro progettano grattacieli per gatti,
qui c'è Francesco Gatti, l'ha fatto lui,
progettano monumenti, progettano
giardini, orti sociali,
progettano luoghi per bambini, per
adulti, persino per marziani.
E la settimana scorsa siamo stati
a Roma, a Tor Pignattara
e abbiamo avuto il privilegio di lavorare
con 40 bambini di 24 nazionalità
differenti.
E pensate, la scuola che è nata a Favara
un anno fa, con Poltrona Frau,
grazie al sostegno di Poltrona Frau,
sta girando il mondo.
Siamo stati a Londra e abbiamo collaborato
con Deyan Sudjic,
il direttore del Design Museum di Londra.
Tra due settimane saremo a Shangai
e poi ancora a Parigi dove incontreremo
Sou Fujimoto al quale abbiamo dedicato
il nome della scuola di architettura
e poi ancora a Milano e New York.
Vi devo dire, con molto orgoglio, che
quello che stanno facendo i nostri bambini
a Favara, i bambini di Londra, di New York
e anche di Parigi
possono solo sognare di farlo.
Ma Farm è anche il luogo in cui ci
prendiamo cura degli adolescenti.
Abbiamo un festival, che si chiama
Opp, quest'anno la seconda edizione,
co-progettato con gli adolescenti.
Ci prendiamo cura dei giovani, del talento
Ci prendiamo cura degli artisti.
Ci prendiamo cura anche delle persone che
ospitiamo nel nostro paese.
Perché Farm, non è un museo tradizionale.
Farm non ha una collezione di arte
contemporanea.
Da noi le opere sono spesso immateriali,
intangibili. Il più delle volte effimere.
Quello che conta, realmente, da noi è
il valore delle persone che passano.
Per questo ogni tanto utilizziamo
l'espressione:
"Museo delle persone".
Tutto questo ha generato un'onda
di entusiasmo incredibile,
una voglia di riscatto,
un desiderio di essere attori
di un cambiamento,
che ha portato tanti giovani
imprenditori, professionisti,
a dare il loro massimo per cambiare
questa città.
Sentite cosa dicono loro di quello
che sta accadendo:
Maria Cristina di Carlentini:
"A Favara sta succedendo ciò che
dovrebbe succedere in ogni parte
del mondo."
Anna Alba: "C'è un forte senso di
solidarietà, c'è una sana competizione,
una sana voglia di far crescere
la propria città."
Nicola Costanza: "Favara non è più paese
da cui si scappa, da cui si va via,
da cui si pigliano armi e bagagli e si
emigra."
Francesco Gatti: "C'è un'energia, una
forte energia, giovani, sembra di stare
in un posto come Berlino,
che non ti aspetteresti mai di
trovare in mezzo alla Sicilia."
"Ci ha dato a tutti la forza di, come
dire, guardare dentro e dare una mano.
Di creare comunità, di far sì che ognuno
di noi potesse dare il meglio di sé."
Antonio Alba: "Ma il cambiamento più
significativo è la fiducia dei cittadini,
nella fiducia di cambiare le cose.
C'è la consapevolezza e la forza di dire:
È possibile cambiare le cose, attraverso
il sacrificio, l'impegno e la volontà. "
Rosario Castellana: "Credere in se stessi
ma come comunità, come cittadini.
C'è qualcuno che crede che Favara
possa scrivere delle pagine di storia."
(musica)
Favara, in passato, quando andava bene
era la città dell'agnello pasquale.
Il più delle volte era la città della
mafia, dei latitanti, dell'abusivismo.
Oggi Favara è diventata la città
dei giovani, della sperimentazione,
della creatività.
Favara è diventata una piccola capitale
della rigenerazione urbana.
E pensate, in un luogo in cui non arrivava
un turista, neanche per sbaglio,
oggi, da più di tre anni, registriamo più
di centomila presenze ogni estate.
Io credo che ognuno di noi ha la
sensazione, le grandi città del mondo,
le città più belle del mondo,
siano nate tali, così come le percepiamo.
Facciamo fatica, in realtà, a pensare
che persone esattamente come noi,
con due braccia, due gambe e
una bella testa,
le hanno fatte diventare quelle
che oggi sono, queste città.
E allora, credo, fortemente, che
le città cambino, perché le persone
le fanno cambiare.
Detta così sembra una passeggiata
di salute,
in realtà stiamo lavorando ad un
progetto molto più grande di noi.
Quest'estate, pensate,
abbiamo dovuto anche
sventare un attacco
della burocrazia locale.
Ordine di demolizione e rimessa
in pristino di cinque installazioni
di architetti contemporanei,
laddove avevamo fatto la richiesta
regolare di autorizzazione e
avevamo pagato il suolo pubblico.
Per fortuna è bastata una semplice
lettera su Facebook per sollevare
un muro a nostra protezione.
Tutti i media nazionali ne hanno parlato
e persino la procura della Repubblica
il 15 di agosto, per Ferragosto,
ha ordinato agli stessi vigili,
che avevano messo i sigilli, di andare a
rimuoverli e di liberare la Farm.
E allora, capite che le cose si possono
fare
e che dipende da noi
dobbiamo semplicemente,
noi che siamo un po' più fortunati,
provare a restituire qualcosa indietro.
Io sono certo che in questa sala,
tra queste novecento persone
ci saranno tantissimi di voi che hanno
avuto una volta il desiderio di fare
qualcosa di speciale.
Eppure ci sarà stato qualcuno che accanto
a voi, un familiare, un parente, un amico,
vi ha detto: "No, questa cosa non la
puoi fare. É impossibile.
Non ce la puoi fare."
Sapete cosa vi dico?
Si sbagliano.
E allora vi voglio lasciare
con un desiderio.
Ve lo leggo:
"Il mio desiderio è che questa sera,
ognuno di voi possa chiedersi
cosa potrebbe fare per rendervi
felici e orgogliosi di voi stessi,
pensando cosa potreste fare per voi
e per chi vi sta vicino,
per i vostri figli
e per le future generazioni,
per la vostra città,
per il nostro Paese."
E soprattutto che domani mattina,
domenica, 12 novembre 2017,
iniziate a farlo.
Grazie
(applauso)